[Applause]
[Music]
just behind today we're talking about
live practice in Aikido so how can we
make live training drills in IKEA Joshua
Maia here yes alright so remember a
night you know we're trying to build
purpose-built training drills so that
way we're working on IKEA or not working
on some other martial art master rating
in his Aikido right so we don't want to
work boxing drills because we're not a
boxing school if you want to get good at
boxing go to boxing gym they've got
better drills they got better people to
attack to you and work your heart if
we're doing wrestling drills like you
know well that's bad because going in
wrestling gym you'll be around people
who actually wrestle on are good at
wrestling and that's a way to get good
at that and I think we have to get good
at the skill sets that Aikido is really
good at and today we're gonna talk about
some of the distancing practices she's
gonna be hard so we have a limited frame
here so it's gonna be a little contrived
but you got to be able to get the idea
now we're gonna we're gonna do it with
this guy so this is a pool move right it
doesn't hurt when you get hit with it
right it makes a loud noise but it
doesn't hurt now that's really
advantageous for a practice because if I
give this to one of the guys Maya
doesn't have to worry about getting hit
in the head so that will symbolize
someone who's really aggressive and
doesn't care that you're gonna hit it
now if she feigns that it's gonna hurt
every time then we're not training our
nage / situation where you get some
really tough person who doesn't care if
you gotta let I for a knife or a machete
or whatever they're charging anyway so
we're training Josh to deal with someone
in the worst situation someone who
doesn't even care about the weapon and
is going to come in for it at the same
time we're teaching josh to just
continue to make shots with the weapon
which is great because that weapon will
eventually add up right to him we got a
really tough person you hit into six or
seven times with the machete even the
toughest person is gonna stop
functioning very well right so it is
going to work for him just in this drill
or taking that away so we don't have any
any all sense of like oh you know this
guy oh I'm scared with my
or whatever right so just about full
moon which is great you can hit full
steam it should hit full steam
now the first drill we're going to do is
simply mine is going to come in to shove
Josh just she's gonna get out of the way
and hits you just gonna make suppression
and hit so it looks like this just
simply getting off the line and get in
mine one more time there we go see nice
positions for them he getting out of
there instead okay so that's one thing
we got to Train everybody to do is that
you want to get off the line and you
want to hit Josh if he's having any
tendency to stay on the line in hit
we've got to get rid of that so if I
came in and Josh get to look like this
[Applause]
good could be this right Maya comes in
it looks like this okay so oh man I
really feel good about myself you see
how many times I hit her but if this is
a piece of a person we just got a hard
hat on right through this no good right
that's no no good for it so we can't
turn that josh has to teach himself to
get off the line and hit so as she's
coming in he gets off the line and get
to see how nice suppression there really
looks good so it's hard for her to come
in okay next drill in this is gonna be
my coming in and trying to adapt to Josh
and get a hold of him while he's hitting
and moving good so we see that kind of
situation now mine gets just around the
waist we're just gonna call it a loss
for Josh right now so she's gonna come
in and try and get Josh
do you see the idea of you know - trying
to get a Red Cross expression get a
whole team Josh is training himself to
stay out of range and hit her can we can
build this up more and more aggressively
and ideally what we're going to be doing
is doing it in a three situation where
they can use the hold map we're not
gonna have that right now and I can try
and trap Josh eight corners and do all
kinds of other stuff we're gonna have
him run essentially a little Gio Russell
right now while josh is working on that
weapon
good job all right so you can see there
he's trying to constantly get out of the
way and deal with my in that situation
so nice practice for that okay now what
we didn't see in that was Maya trying to
get a hold of the weapon or Josh's arm
so let's just see what that would look
like in pretend here for a second so
Maya comes in Josh goes to swing in mind
checks that hands okay boom she got it
now what we have here is a little bit of
an awkward but essentially hukka talk
they'd order right this is a real easy
katate dori four drops to escape so we
have that situation going on now Josh
should be training to get out of this
and clear the weapon hand okay
there we go I see no good news we're
gonna run the drill and if Maya sees the
weapon and he grabbed all the weapon
she's gonna grab a hole through the
weapon
ready
okay
so you can see here a progression that
we can build with this now of course we
could add two attackers to that or make
it more confined space there's all kinds
of criteria we can use to build that up
but the idea is that you giving each
other get both of them win criteria
mines win criteria you know holds ajosh
in a way that you can't use that weapon
Jobs's win criteria simply stay free use
that weapon as much as possible
this falls in line with our Aikido ideas
and we'll train this to use I knew as a
martial art instead of using some other
system right so if I'm training some
kind of wrestling system and she comes
in there might be it might be this Oh
God right I know I did a rimi nage there
so that was really Aikido but I ignored
all the other ideas of Aikido when she
comes in I want to be able to keep
distance manage my I use my weapon it's
the only successfully blend right so
this is all the stuff that we're trying
to learn in IKEA so our live hots this
hack to mimic that I'm Christopher hein
thanks for watching
[Music]